look i'm not saying this comic basically
confirms that nightmare is going to be
in doctor strange too i'm just saying
remember when marvel released that story
where wolverine fought blade and then we
covered it and i was like the only
reason they're doing this story is
because they're going to announce
something about blade and then like two
days later they announced something
about blade this feels like that
[Laughter]
so first things first um this is a
terribly written story it's written by
ralph macchio no not ralph macchio from
karatekid don't worry i looked it up too
[Laughter]
nonetheless this story is
it's written very much in the same way
the stanley and jack kirby used to write
doctor strange stories back in the 60s
right where like doctor strange would
cast a spell but it would just be him
doing something and just saying it in a
magic sounding way you know like i cast
the spell of a dozen eggs for we are low
on eggs and need more right it's
basically that what this does is it
initially picks up with baron mordo
right and baron mordo basically conjures
up his astral form and then travels to
the dream dimension to meet with
nightmare and what we find out is that
what nightmare has been doing has been
subtly influencing the dreams of dr
strange that literally he's been kind of
forcing steven strange to relive his own
experiences really is on origin multiple
times but each time he does it kind of
erodes a little bit away from him now
the other part of this and i don't even
know how you explain this the other part
there's literally this point right where
like nightmare's talking about how
powerful he is and he says within this
hand i hold several of the supposedly
all-powerful beyonders who invaded my
realm years ago and their ill-conceived
attempt to conquer the multiverse i have
toyed with them long enough see now all
their vaunted energies have dissipated
in this place beyond the pale they have
learned the error of their ways too late
so basically marvel's confirming that
nightmare is more powerful than the
beyonders and i don't even know how you
explain that there's only one there's
only one way to explain this right so
for those of you guys who don't know
what the beyonders are and i don't know
anybody who doesn't at this point in
time those are guys who don't know what
the beyonders are these guys killed the
multiverse not technically technically
it was doctor doom and molecule man who
did it and steven strange really an army
of molecule man but the important thing
here is there was a point in jonathan
hickman's avengers new avengers i mean
seeing this in the comic this is
obviously a sign i need to go back and
read hickman's avengers new avengers and
secret wars again but uh but the thing
about this is the beyonders killed all
the cosmic entities across the
multiverse and then killed the living
tribunal and it was actually these three
who did it depending on on how you look
at it i don't know any other way to look
at it they were the second most powerful
being to the one above all i don't know
that they could have defeated the one
above all and we never found out but
what marvel's basically saying here is
at some point along the line the
beyonders traveled to the realm of of
the dream dimension they traveled to
nightmare's well and in doing so
nightmare stripped them of their powers
and then has basically been tormenting
them ever since and then got rid of them
right literally just kills them here and
like that's it it's nuts man it's kind
of ridiculous but the bigger takeaway
from this is the beyonders were
destroying were like killing things
across the multiverse remember the
ultimate universe has been reborn and
it's been here for a little while but we
haven't seen hide nor hair of nightmare
in the ultimate universe what i think
marvel's doing here is they're moving in
the direction of saying nightmare is a
multiversal being this is seemingly
verified by marvel overture that story
that we covered and never really
finished where basically nightmare
defeated the living tribunal right there
they're like what marvel's doing since
the announcement of doctor strange too
what marvel has seemingly been doing is
amping up the power of nightmare to
present him as this guy this just this
ridiculously op character because in
years past nightmare was powerful sure i
guess but he was never anybody who was
on par with like the beyonders or the
living tribunal he was just a dick that
would make you relive bad dreams and
that was it right like this that's
literally all he was nothing more than
that but like they're amping this guy's
powers up in ridiculously high levels
but the other reason why i say this
basically kind of confirms nightmare
being in doctor strange too
is because the task at hand and the
reason why nightmares basically been
screwing with the dreams of doctor
strange which looks like it's what's
happening in the dreams little mini
trailer that we got for doctor strange 2
into the multiverse of madness is that
the whole goal is for baron mordo to
basically enter into the sanctum satorum
of doctor strange and to steal the dark
hold and in doing so use the dark hole
to bring nightmare into into the the
main marvel universe and that baron
mordo would basically rule the earthly
dimension right basically the main
marvel universe as a whole while
nightmare just rules the dream dimension
and seemingly everything else right so
essentially like what we're talking
about here is nightmare entering into
their realm and then by doing so
conquering the multiverse and and
basically baron mordo would rule the
main marvel universe and that would
basically be it it's kind of nuts man
like it's i mean you guys see this right
like i'm not making like it's not like
i'm interpreting this the wrong way
right like you guys see kind of what's
going on here right now having said that
the rest of the story is written like
garbage but here's the thing
[Music]
what goes on is you switch over to
doctor strange and effectively doctor
strange is having these conversations
with wong but he's talking about how he
just he's restless all the time he can
never really sleep his anxiety is really
high his favorite restaurant closed
that's not true but it probably can
probably didn't help right if that was
the case but nonetheless right it's just
his life is kind of in he's really in
mental and emotional turmoil and one of
the things that happens is as he goes
back to bed in order to rest ralph
macchio just kind of gives us this like
i don't know five or four page
explanation of like doctor strange's
origin literally this comic one it's a
one-off right so it's just a one-shot
comic there are no sequels to this not
that i'm aware of um and two it's
designed to be like a new reader's entry
into doctor strange so if you're a
person who's never read comics and you
want to get into doctor strange and you
stumble upon this you're going to be
like this feels a lot like doctor
strange to you into the multiverse of
madness i have to believe that's what
they were shooting for but in the middle
of all this of course because steven
strange is kind of kind of reliving his
own origin over and over and over again
where of course he's basically a very
arrogant surgeon he's ends up being
caught in a car wreck he loses the
ability to use his hands for surgery
because of the damage they sustain to
the nerves he ends up going for all
these different treatments stumbles
across the ancient one the ancient one
basically helps them become the sorcerer
supreme or teaches him magic anyway
baron mordo is basically a dick and then
ultimately because of stephen strange
exposing baron mordo is a bad guy the
ancient one brings him on full time
baron mordo kind of sticks around for a
while and then gets the boot and then
we're here like that's basically it but
the whole thing behind this is of course
wang basically grabbing him as a result
of him having this bad dream and the two
of them talking about how there has to
be something more to this and stephen
strange simply just having having a
series of bad dreams right i mean he's
the source for supreme and for the most
part steven strange has like his mental
and emotional state on lockdown so if he
suddenly starts starts experiencing all
these really bad dreams all these these
kind of crazy situations somebody has to
be doing something and where they
initially have this bit of a discussion
of okay well maybe it might have
something to do with nightmare i mean he
has always kind of done this to me
before it's also really more steven
strange as a result of his dreams
questioning himself his confidence
begins to wax and wayne and that's when
baron mordo makes his presence known now
following this this is where i say this
comic is
it's written like amateur hour right so
just the dialogue and like the talking
between the two right so literally like
baron mordo shows up here early stephen
strange greets him and is like such an
entrance will you compensate me for the
shattered door and then baron mordo says
bravado your deteriorated physical state
allowed me to penetrate the mystical
barrier around your domicile that relies
on your well-being i came from my castle
in search of the unique volume you keep
here the dark hole and stephen strange
is like that thrice-cursed home has been
in my keeping for many years mordo and
considering the dangerous and diabolical
nature of the spells on its weathered
pages i have no intention of passing it
to the likes of you and then he casts a
spell and mordo says such a feeble spell
i expected more from the fabled sorcerer
supreme can it be something troubles you
and he says it seems ages ago since we
vied for the ancient one's attention if
only he were present to see you in such
disarray and then dr strange replies
you were kept on as his disciple only so
he could keep an eye on you preventing
you from communicating with the
malignant forces that would enslave our
world like you see what i'm saying like
it's just it's it's written bad man like
it's just bad it's just
i don't know how else to explain this
it's written like a like a poorly
written soap opera like it's just ha ha
i know you baron mordo enter explanation
of who you are in overly dramatic and
magicky sounding words you know and it's
just like okay you know i i guess
but there are some cool spells that get
that they get cast here for example uh
we basically end up seeing like the
vipers of valtor now again we've seen
the vipers of valve's war throughout
doctor strange comics a lot the timing
of this is just really intriguing right
we're literally like that's what we saw
in the doctor strange too multiverse of
madness trailer
right so it is cool to see those things
of course you do end up seeing the clamp
of sidorak i mean again like just just
to drive this home guys just to drive
this home there's a point when the the
vipers are cast right dr strange says no
i'll not succumb to this i bring forth a
spell of banishment to send these
slithering horrors away and the response
of baron mordo is let the clinging clamp
of sidorak silence your voice so that
not another spell may issue from your
lips and doctor strange says go
[Laughter]
i'm just throwing it out here guys it's
just it's written really really really
bad but the important thing here is that
ultimately baron mordo ends up getting
his hands on the dark hole and then
basically leaving now here's the
important thing about this as far as i'm
aware in my knowledge of my doctor
strange mythos and again i'm by no means
as knowledgeable with dr strange's
history as i am with say like the x-men
or something like that but i know a lot
i'm not aware of there being really any
instances where anybody got their hands
on the dark hole for the purpose of
summoning nightmare into the main the
main marvel universe more often than not
it's usually nightmare trying to find
his own way into the main marvel
universe so putting people to sleep or
using dr strange as a vessel so he can
try to take over doctor strange's body
and then enter into the realm of the
main marvel universe i mean dr strange
kind of looks like benedict cumberbatch
anyway so you know it's just one of
those things right where where it looks
like it's really being written more
because it's based on what's going to be
happening in doctor strange to the
multiverse of madness than anything else
but essentially you basically pick up in
transylvania where you end up having
baron mordo who of course summons these
or uses these various spells and in
doing so opens a barrier to the dream
dimension right opens a barrier not even
really to the dream dimension but to the
realms of the fear lords now one of the
things that we should probably do
depending on how things unfold with
doctor strange too we should probably
create a hierarchy video that focuses on
the the various fear lords that are out
there right like the demon beings that
are out there because technically you
have the dweller in darkness who's the
most powerful of them all and then you
have nightmare and then you have several
others that kind of fit around there but
more recently it looks like nightmare is
the most powerful out of all of them and
it's always kind of been that way but
just unofficially confirmed in marvel to
be honest with you that like nightmare
is powered by literally the nightmares
of all sentient beings and that's what
marvel overture established right what
would happen if nightmare basically put
the world to sleep and then fed off the
world's dreams how would that unfold and
what would it look like that was the
answer to the question that we got like
he would just become ridiculously op
it's an infinite source of power by just
a ridiculously infinite source of power
that allows him to basically take on all
comers which included the living
tribunal i mean i'm not gonna lie it was
a little hard for me to accept right
that nightmare could take on the living
tribunal i was like i mean i'll swallow
this pill it's an enormous pill but i'll
swallow it you know we'll see what
happens and the story was cool until the
end but the thing about this is that uh
that literally with this this kind of
rift being opened up this sort of
fissure this tear between uh between
realities between dimensions of course
doctor strange arrives just in time and
then a fight breaks out between the two
of them again now because of what's
going on here and because doctor strange
is realizing that it's basically
nightmare who has been infecting him or
forcing him to relive these same dream
sequences over and over again uh he
really just kind of begins to take
himself back right his confidence begins
to re-emerge again all that kind of
stuff his heart grows three sizes bigger
than it was before and then ultimately
he ends up basically defeating mordo
right basically overcoming mordo taking
him out and that's basically the end of
him he doesn't kill him right he doesn't
really kill mordo but this is a moment
whereby nightmare is momentarily able to
make his way into into this realm now
one of the things that i want to point
out here is this kind of a big deal
because as far as i'm aware this is
about as close as nightmare has gotten
to being able to tangibly invade the
main marvel universe right like
physically showing up here in this realm
in a way that allows him to stay here he
has shown up in the realm before but
it's one of those things where like he
appears for like a little bit and then
ultimately ends up having to go back
because much like mephisto the longer
he's away from his realm the weaker he
becomes and he's already weak as soon as
he leaves so then that weakness just
kind of increases as time goes on but
even at a weakened point because of
where doctor strange is nightmare could
still overcome him and so stephen
strange does the only thing he really
can do here i mean it literally gets to
the point where like nightmare just
seizes control of baron mordo with the
intention of taking him away right and
literally he's like help me you know
save me and stephen strange i mean it's
kind of a dick thing right so stephen
strange responds and he was like you
were willing to sacrifice our very
reality and all his inhabitants in
pursuit of your mad dreams you wanted
nightmare's world to devour ours so you
could rule by his side now let the
scales be balanced and it devour you
essentially baron mordo is begging for
his life and stephen strange is like
sorry about your luck i don't know what
to tell you but basically he closes the
portal
and so seemingly baron mordo is whisked
away to the realm of nightmare and like
that's it right like that's the end of
him and then of turn of course because
the day is saved you end up having
steven strange that take you know he
takes the dark hole back to his sanctum
satorum puts it back on the bookshelf
and then finally gets some peaceful
sleep now here's one of the things that
i want to establish here this does not
feel like it's in the main marvel
universe right i mean it it could be and
that's why i'm kind of ill you know
alluding to this fact or referencing the
main marvel universe because it could
very well be in the main marvel universe
we haven't seen baron mordo since the
events of the death of doctor strange
and that was kind of like the death of
the actual doctor strange and now
there's a new one right clea is the new
doctor strange in in marvel comics uh so
it looks i mean from what i could tell
stephen strange may very well die at the
end of doctor strange too multiverse of
madness those you guys who understand
why it used to be the marvel cinematic
universe follow the comics but as the
mcu became so ridiculously popular and
as they started realizing that they
could basically get away with crafting
their own stories now it's the other way
around and the comics usually follow the
movies and so with the death of dr
strange story being a pretty significant
story at the time that essentially
there's no more doctor strange cleo
stepped into that role and so it seems
like that may very well be what's going
on in doctor strange too that steven
strange is gonna die at the end of that
at the end of that movie i don't really
know that's gonna be the case or not
supposedly he's supposed to have more
projects than things he's supposed to be
a part of so i don't know write us
anybody's guess and we won't really even
know until the movie comes out but uh
yeah that's basically what's going on
here terribly written story but it's got
some amazing moments in it so with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
to an end
and i will catch you all later
peace